the alizay family from afghanistan is
having to move
along with another thousand refugees
they're being forced to leave the home
they've known for almost two years
at the karate bear community instead
they're being put in a tent city down
the road called mavrovunyo
their 17 year old daughter anise is a
gifted mathematician
who beat local greek students for a
place at the island's top high school
now she doesn't know if she'll be able
to sit university entrance exams next
year
a tent that does not have a door does
not make you feel safe
in karatepay we have a container and you
can close it when you go to bed at night
they have covered 19 cases which we
don't have at karatepay
and i think that will make greek parents
worry about
us travelling from the camp to go to
school with their children
this afghan family already lives at
motherhood
they say there's no daycare or school
for their daughters aged
six and nine doctors without borders say
they've had patients raped at the new
camp
despite government assurances that it's
safe in the night time
you feel too scared to go outside of
your tents
certainly if you're a woman you will not
go to the toilet every aspect of this
camp
for me is set up in a way
to to deter people
to to dehumanize them to to predict that
they don't have basic human needs
the government didn't allow us to film
inside the camp apparently due to covert
restrictions
but an aid worker confirmed talk of
discomfort here
there's no proper drainage there's no
proper heating there's
the electricity is insufficient to keep
your tents warm at night
every time it rains it floods the
wash facilities are inadequate it's
not clean these are the very problems
that plagued moria
the largest camp in the east aegean
mavrovonio was set up as a temporary
facility
after maurya burnt down in september
police say due to arson
now it feels like a lost civilization
looted for manholes and wire fence
garatepe feels more like a village
community than a refugee camp
and that's why so many disabled and
other vulnerable refugees
were moved there from moria the hastily
landscaped artillery range
they're going to resembles moria in many
respects
aid groups say it's a great step
backwards
the european union has poured more than
a billion dollars into refugee care in
greece in the past five years
and is now spending more than 300
million dollars to build
better camps on the aegean islands many
of these asylum seekers now displaced
several times over
wonder why europe with such resources
cannot offer them a home
john cerropolos al jazeera lesbos